our next speaker is so thanks a lot I'm
really happy to be here I really see my
time here is doing a lot of learning
about the set of issues but I did want
to make a few remarks at this point so I
wanted to begin with by saying you know
my exploration of issues related to the
topics of the workshop have been in some
respects quite recent and in other
respects
I've watched how certain biases both
racial biases sexism have become
embedded in both the content of a wide
range of algorithm based systems and the
culture and communities in which that
work has been done so just to date
myself when I learned to code and work
as a software engineer developing
applications in the early 1970s through
the mid 1980s I was usually the only
African American woman only African
American and one of the few women in my
classes and in the companies where I
worked and these environments were
certainly dominated by white men many
who I viewed as immature and socially
uncomfortable with the presence of women
and especially with the presence of
women women and men of color and it was
a world where the culture actually
mirrored the kind of command control
structure that was embedded in the code
that we produced and as that culture
I wanted that culture kind of morphed
into the Silicon Valley world we know
today where corporate workplaces are
more like engineering school campuses
and the diversity of the workforce
certainly has changed it's more
international for one but yet the
presence of African Americans and
Latinos as engineers and members of the
technical staff remain abysmally low so
I just wanted to show you to begin with
just one
okay then do I know how to use this okay
just one set of data from the Google
2019 diversity report
I hope it's very hard to see can you see
it at all right you can't even see it
from the front row okay look I'll tell
you so right here is 2019 this is what
you get when you make your slice in the
plane right so these slides are gonna be
terrible that's all I can say so the
report for the first time 2019 Google
diversity report included data from
employees who were differently abled as
well as those who are LGBTQ and what it
shows is a slight increase in tech hires
for females from twenty four point six
percent of their workforce in 2017 to
twenty five point seven percent this
year yeah huge right for the tech hires
for blacks Latinos and Native Americans
the numbers are four point eight percent
of the tech worst workforce for blacks
six point eight percent of the tech
workforce for Latinos and 1.1 percent
for Native Americans and the tech hires
of african-american females increased to
two point two percent which they're very
proud of to state the obvious in most
respects Google remains a kind of
monoculture where the social
implications of tools they develop are
understudied but clearly designed to
reflect the values and interests of one
segment of our population so as I said
I'm here to sort of engage with you all
in the conversation and learn more about
especially the algorithm based work how
it actually gets done so I just want to
focus on really two points where I
question how biomedicine still reflects
pass understandings of race number one
and number two assumes that assumes that
these past understandings I want to make
the point that they cannot be easily
undone so
one question I was going to ask at the
end of the last session is to say
something I think is really important
for all of us to understand the entire
us-based medical system is deeply
inescapably dependent on certain
presumptions about race racial
difference and biological differences
between human groups and it has been so
since at least the 17th century so the
examples that Dorothy gave of Cartwright
who talked about the pet amania black
people running away that kind of
attitude and presumption of difference
goes forward in time and there is no
time that at least historians have been
able to document when that was not the
case when the presumption of biological
difference between groups in the US was
not the presumption of American medical
people as we don't know when that time
was so I think for all of us trying to
do work on sort of thinking about the
biases built-in we have to start from
that premise they are there they are
everywhere and a lot of that is
something that I think we as I said I
think we have to pay attention to so as
you as you what I want to turn to
announce the ways in which some of the
classifications and racial categories
have been used in medicine I just want
to give one example I mean as you well
know classification systems have a long
history they're part of them the
scientific understanding of both peoples
and societies and as many people have
noted they've been extensive histories
written about how racial classification
emerged in 18th and 19th centuries in
North America as a paradigm of
differentiation that would support the
exclusion of certain groups from social
and political life and today as in the
past Library and Information science
organization systems have used in their
subject catalogs and classification
systems that they create they've played
an important part of understanding the
landscape of how information and now
sort of disciplines of information
science have inherited and continue and
contribute to I should say certain kinds
of biased practices in their system
designs especially on the web so
I just want to add to some of the
previous speakers comment about the
problems associated with the use of
concepts of biological race so what I
want to turn to is that in the late
1990s historians of Medicine
bioethicists others questioned how race
and ethnicity were defined in the
midline of database so some of you may
know I'm sure most of you know if you've
tried to download any sort of biomedical
life sciences articles it's the US
National Library of Medicine it's their
premier bibliographic database that
contains more than 25 million references
to the journal articles in the life
sciences and biomedicine the database is
indexed with National Library of
Medicine medical subject headings called
the mesh and so some historians of
Medicine certainly in some of the folks
I've been working with for a long time
we wanted to understand how you could
use in the Nash the the MEDLINE database
to trace the use of racial categories
and cataloguing and indexing biomedical
articles over time and we questioned
whether and how and if older and
strictly typological concepts of race
those are based on the notion of
biological differences and how that and
how issues of ethnicity were used in
MEDLINE as if they were used in the same
way as the precursor to MEDLINE which is
called index Medicus had used those
terms so we know that MEDLINE has to
organize thousands of topics into an
indexing system to strike a balance
between that old system that they had
which was absolutely riven with
categories of race and current interests
so in the race workshop that I convened
at MIT and Harvard for about 15 years
our motley crew of historians physicians
biologists sociologists feminists and
STS scholars were constantly trying to
tease apart what was happening
in the MEDLINE system and really try to
see if we could use it to build our
timelines about how racial concepts
maybe had changed over time in the
biomedical and life sciences disciplines
and whether or not discredited racial
terms were being used in papers that
were really focused on human genetic
variation in the age of genomics was all
that how was that passed set of
categories being carry for is the kind
of questions that we've been asking so
this is just when the front page from
the midline site and so Pam Sacco sankar
in 2003 wrote this article on on MEDLINE
definitions of race and ethnicity in the
application to genetic research same
cars a bioethicists and she showed how
these categories were used to index the
articles using the medical subject
headings and she showed that they were
many of them were decades old and
inconsistent so this was published in
2003 so when she did a search for race
in mesh it returned racial stocks right
which mesh defined as quote major living
subspecies of man differentiated by
genetic and physical characteristics so
the notion that that races are
subspecies right there front and center
it listed for races Caucasoid [ __ ]
negroid and Australoid and defined each
of the first three is a major racial
group determined distinguished according
to physical features I'm going to keep
saying this is 2003
so was interesting also is that while
the mesh sort of distinguish between
race racial stocks and ethnic groups the
former on that is racial stocks were
designated for indexing articles that
concern of populations physical
characteristics where the latter
indicated articles about what they
called cultural psychological social
sociological or ethnological aspects no
further information was provided and
those distinctions were allowed to stand
and as I said she conducted this in in
2002 and then in 2003 found that the
indexers applied the distinction between
racial stocks and ethnic groups so
inconsistently that in some categories
as many as thirty percent of the
articles conforming to racial stock
criteria where instead indexed to
something called ethnic groups so what
she said in this article is she
concluded that the mesh indexing needed
to be reconsidered and reviewed and
taken and what needed to leave that
system were these old terms like
Caucasoid [ __ ] and all of those
because they were outmoded they came
from a kind of colonialists legacy and
needed to be a really seriously review
in response the National Library of
Medicine admitted that they were
outmoded and they promised to make
substantial revisions and produce new
notes that went along with the
categories but they also noted in that
quote raises an unscientific concept
nonetheless even a cursory review of
current literature shows that studies in
which groups are described by implied or
explicit racial characteristics continue
to be published and to contribute to a
deeper understanding of human biology
this that sentence has many pieces that
be Tiffany taken apart and they may
close by saying we hope that the revised
treatment of racial and ethnic groups in
the 2004 edition of mesh will remove
offensive terminology
but we'll still allow the indexers to
describe topics that are discussed in
the literature indexed in MEDLINE so the
scope notes which are these notes that
are shown along side of the when you do
a search we're first developed to give
the index of aid to help them understand
how they could sort write you know how
to put things in various buckets but
they noted in one of the discussions of
this this switch that was happening
around 2003 2004 that they argued that
what once MEDLINE became a free public
database that had become it had come
under increasing public scrutiny because
researchers and the public did not
understand why there were certain
categories being used to describe racial
groups and ethnic groups and that really
actually made them that was actually the
push not a letter from a bioethicists
the push to get them to rethink how they
were doing this I think it was really
interesting that they say race this has
been unscientific concept but it's going
to deepen our understanding of human
biology so so I made only a brief a
really brief foray into what is
happening to MEDLINE today I just really
did a short check and they have a new
product called mesh on-demand and I'm
just gonna show you a few screenshots so
I put in race that was just yesterday
continental puppet comes up with
Continental population groups these are
groups of individuals whose putative
ancestry is from native continental
populations based on similarities and
physical characteristical appearance and
then they have these entry terms race
and racial stocks not gone anywhere
then you search on Continental
population groups you get groups of
individuals whose putative ancestry is
from native continental populations
based on similarities in physical
appearance so I you know we can talk
about this but as you can see it's not
clear how much more helpful this is for
those of us are using almost weekly or
daily this this is this is absurd
and so I think it limits to which what
other ones I have
so here's a screenshot if you can see
this one it has the top one is European
or continental ancestry these are
individuals whose ancestral origins are
in the continent of Europe then it you
could also they could have also put that
in the bucket called white which are an
ethnic group of putative Caucasoid
origin the people were white know that
then if you put in caucus or race it's a
group distinguished by classification
according to physical features this
group also called Europe point centers
around the Mediterranean Sea but
includes other parts of Europe other
parts of Europe and they took those
definitions from in one of them of the
American Heritage Dictionary second
college edition that's the dictionary
they after apology 1972 okay that's the
term you put in to search for and it
comes up with a list of articles
referred to that that keyword sort of so
if I want articles on race I put in race
and I get the set of a set of articles
that they've deemed have that as a major
keyword in the abstract which they use
to sort it
oh that was good okay oh well I'll tell
you I'll tell you more the wire that
connects to your computer
anyway okay but let me thank you I'm
sorry it's me it's me it's not the
machine
thank you it's this one yes right okay
but you can still search for negroid and
additional terms that would come up with
that are seen right here on the side
humans a mega part no not quite
that way you can get the full text
though it takes a few places her humans
African Continental ancestry group
European continental ancestry group it
comes up with articles related to
genetic homogeneity among the negroid
and Arabic tribes of the Sudan study of
30 DNA markers in three southern African
populations so Negro gets you to those
kind of articles ok [ __ ]
similarly refers to humans Asian
continental ancestry group and also for
folks who have for information about
Down syndrome manga Lord is a very old
and discredited term to describe people
with Down syndrome and then Caucasoid
again European continental ancestry
group and it goes from everything from
evaluation of the relative contribution
of Caucasoid and [ __ ] components in
the formation of ethnic groups to new
classifications of alleles in rheumatoid
arthritis susceptibility so I think I
made my point that these whole terms
that carry very different meanings
historically and quote-unquote
biologically are still embedded in this
system how you the problem they faced
was how you get it out and I think it's
very clear from a couple of people that
I've talked to that they don't know how
to get it out right now and that is a
very serious problem for them and then
and when you go
to the new mesh on-demand the last thing
you see is measured demands suggested
mesh vocabulary are machine generated by
MTI I don't know who MT is and do not
reflect any human review mt i may
recommend mesh terms not explicitly
found in the text so they actually
they're machine learning program
actually might be catching those older
terms up because that's what's built in
for it to do because I can't imagine I
probably you know it's looking for
something contemporary I wouldn't put in
negroid I mean I thought it seems that
that the system is doing that in part
representing that so the question for
them is what to do about the new systems
machine generated response and and it's
not I'm not objecting to the problem of
a machine generated response in my view
the problem is that when you're
searching on issues on for topics
related to race and ethnicity the
database is already Riven with miss
application of these terms and thus at
best reflects the absence of any kind of
consensus on the use of race or
definitions of race in biomedicine and
life sciences research and now the
confusion is embedded in the machine
learning system that's what I think is
embedded a certain kind of confusion
that constantly depending on the kind of
search you're doing that goes back and
forth between something that we think of
is the biological and physical
characteristics and then something
that's referenced and used to race in a
very different way but it's very hard
unless you think about that part of the
problem to disaggregate what you get yes
dueña it's a medical text indexer that
combines the index section in the
library
that their expertise and natural
language processing to curate biomedical
literature more efficiently well I don't
know you think they're working okay
so this my so my point about this is
that first is there's no robust process
available to get public input into
changing the mesh terms MEDLINE is a
publicly funded system they say you can
write in and if you have problems or you
want different mesh terms that they will
collect your ideas and subject it to
some kind of review which they do not
describe and you have no idea if they
how and when the input might change and
it seems that the focus is really
getting the data into the system without
considering and particularly in the use
of these categories what they reflect
about the very definitions that they're
trying to give back to people as they
actually do the searches so I mean
there's much much much more work to be
done and my students have been largely
working in the past with index Medicus
which is much you know in a way much
more consistent in its use of older type
of logical biologically based racial
categories than the current system and
my point is that the current system is
really a confused system much more
sentient so than the older one was and
so I so I think there's there's a lot
more to do and it's very clear there's
no common language that they can draw
upon most fields that present very
clearly guidelines for this though more
the journals are doing so but anyway
that's and so I I when I got to the
bottom line and I saw that this is now
no human review I thought well okay I
don't know how we get race out of this
our older notions of race are specific
kinds of uses of race that are
problematic so that's the point there's
a little opportunity at this point to
really discuss and I think we do need to
discuss the way to disaggregate these
older race concepts from new conceptions
of human
variation and one last thing I wanted to
say when I was also looking around for
what I wanted to talk about today I was
going to review Latanya Sweeney
well sided paper on on privacy and
databases and and algorithms but when I
was going through that journal I decided
to look at all the articles in that
issue and I found really a very
interesting article about encouraging IT
usage and future healthcare this is May
2013 and the author was arguing about
how technology could act as a change
agent for healthcare I just thought her
description of what she envisioned isn't
interesting my first disgust she said
imagine the day when an elderly woman in
India feels ill at birth of genetic code
has been entered into her medical record
since birth she has been able to record
a complete history of time and location
based measurements of her physiological
features for example temperature blood
pressure height and weight and of her
environment for example air and water
quality interactions with people
ubiquitous sensor networks would collect
this information and today she might
record this information using her cell
phone is stored in the cloud she also
might be illiterate but still be able to
manage this information with speech
input and these recordings are part of
her personal medical record which also
includes past interactions with health
and wellness professionals professionals
such as diagnosis intervention
treatments and medical test results she
contacts their doctor they meet in
cyberspace
today this real-time communication could
be virtual though it could be through
avatars on a world on a wall-sized touch
display in her home where there will be
a productive projection of something
that might or not might or might not be
a real doctor for all so she could
demonstrate the pain she gets in moving
her body in certain ways she can
demonstrate the pain she can show the
location and pattern of rashes her
doctor can explain the meaning of a test
result by zooming in on her medical
image or by replaying a video graph and
tomorrow the doctor might be able to
palpate the arm the sore arm in
investigating the problem I mean I can't
even just the beginning
the scenario there's so many places
where we know that there are problems in
the work to do to accomplish what she
imagines for example there's also been
some work on how images of projected on
rashes on different skin colors are very
hard for people to analyze and diagnose
disease from so there's another place
where the skin colour hurts what the
rashes look like if you look at all
medical textbooks you see a lot of this
and you see again this is a racialized
story she talks about the doctor being
able to change the drugs that the person
has been given well we also know that
pharmacogenomics has explicitly been a
race-based project so let me throw the
imagine Paradise future of having all
the data you could possibly want about
an individual's health and be able to to
manage it would be still compromised by
these older notions of race if we don't
address them and the very last point
they make is that she her doctor could
determine the most appropriate treatment
for her a treatment for an elderly
Indian woman will be based on
populations more similar to her rather
than on say middle-aged male Caucasians
who grew up in the United States so the
goal here is to as they say create and
again this is a sentence that I was
deeply struck by a model of the human a
multi-resolution multiscale many
dimensional highly parameterised
computation model of a human body it
relies on data and processing capability
to simulate all systems of the human and
their interactions from the molecular
level to the system's level and any
what-if is possible
[Applause]
yes I'll be in in a month I'll be
joining the faculty at Northeastern very
where where I will have wonderful new
colleagues
so I deliberately had a salad for lunch
instead of a burger so I can try to keep
up my energy level here so what I'd like
to talk about is is essentially sort of
the ideology and algorithms as opposed
to algorithms as a tool specifically in
the space of something known as
behavioural realism and its approaches
to the law behavioural realism is a sort
of liberal response if you will to the
more conservative law and economics
movement and the idea behind it is
trying to use insights from cognitive
and neuro psychology to inform the law
particularly and prominently in the area
of anti-discrimination law equal
protection law where it's been a
proponent propounded by the by a sort of
liberal exponents as a as a way of
trying to break through kind of the dead
end of equal protection law that we're
kind of faced with these days it's
promised on the idea that that implicit
bias is a pervasive continuing endemic
phenomenon but that explicit bias is
something that's largely a phenomenon of
the past which I think you know recently
is sort of call into question and but
also who's against were the leading
exponents say things like you know
America is not today a racist nation
right that it's a problem of implicit
bias not racism and so I had a book come
out last year race on the brain which is
sort of an extended critique of this
whole enterprise but today in particular
I want to focus on
what I call sort of the the techno
philia of this approach in behavioural
realism and specifically the ID the idea
how in certain areas the this
combination of cognitive psychology and
law using the concept or what I would
again sort of call the ideology of AI of
algorithms or techno philia to sort of
informants its approach in very very
problematic ways so discussing the
emergence of modern behavioral
psychology philosopher Desmond Shaw
notes that in 1971 its founding father
or among its founding fathers BF Skinner
quote expressed the hope that the vast
humanly created problems facing our
beautiful planet you know famine war
threat of nuclear holocaust could all be
solved by quote new technologies of
behavior so the idea of this technical
fix to complex social and legal problems
holds a great appeal right it is neat it
is clean its seemingly objective and
powerfully authoritative behavioral
realisms technical fix turns racism into
a function of measurement and
subordinates legal and political
judgment to scientific expertise to the
degree that such subordination comes to
dominate strategies of anti-racist
action it amounts in effect to
outsourcing the hard public and
democratic work of addressing in
injustice to private often corporate
technocrats numerous critiques of the
neoliberal turn in American politics
since the 1980s have decried the
commodification of and of everything
similarly my critique of behavioural
realism takes issue with its urge to
measure everything there is of course a
connection between the two not only in
the impulse towards quantification but
also in the fact that diversity
management and related applications of
behavioural realism have become big
business behavioural realism is deeply
grounded in technologies of measurement
from the millisecond response
calculations of an implicit association
test to the glowing images of an fMRI
measuring purported responses to
coated stimuli behavioural realism
reduces rep racism to a metric
phenomenon real or meaningful only to
the extent that it can be measured by
technological apparatus as devised
implemented assessed by experts
measuring requires quantification of
bias and quantification is seductive
because of the ways in which it
simplifies knowledge and facilitates
decision-making anthropologist Sally
Mary cautions however that quote
counting things require making them
comparable which means they are in in
Ewa tably stripped of their context
history and meaning social psychologists
love to measure prejudice a review of
the I took a look at this book called
the the handbook of multicultural
measures alright
came out a few years ago and it
evaluated no fewer than 37 purported
measures of prejudice you know tools
that are out there
surveys galvanic skin response fMRI
eighties all that stuff right now it's
always trying to measure measure measure
measure measure each measure surely has
its own particular merits but they
cumulatively test testify to a near
fetishization of technologies of
measurement as a foundation for social
psychological approaches to bias we see
this fascination with measurement for
grounded in the very title of jerry king
and Mazarin Banerjee's to do sort of
leading proponents one psychologist one
legal scholar of this i of behavioral
realism and their title of this article
they had come out about a decade ago
called fair measures right a behavioral
realist approach to affirmative action
the contemporary fascination with
measuring racism harks back early to the
19th century scientific obsession with
measuring all aspects of the black body
to establish biological racial
difference this is not to say that
empirical research into the dynamics of
implicit prejudice is unwarranted or
will necessarily yield poor data rather
it is to point up the tendency in
behavioral realism despite the equivocal
Charat caveats repeatedly put out there
by various
it's practitioners that science is not a
magic bullet bullet or to claim that
such empirical work should have but but
rather that they claim the concern is
with the claim that such that they claim
that such empirical work should have
pride of place in establishing legal
baselines for dissent for finding
establishing discrimination and in
crafting legal and policy responses to
such findings always there is the search
for quote objective evidence something
concrete measurable quantifiable the
implication being that other more
sociologically or historically informed
qualitative interpretive methods of
understanding or addressing racism
should take a backseat to the science
behavioural realists embrace scientific
Authority Authority largely in the name
of providing a counterweight to a more
to more conservative quantitative work
of law and economics scholars using the
tools of the enemy against him so to
speak as again as Gerry can for example
sees behavioural realism as so powerfull
precisely because it is grounded quote
in those rigorous and quantitative
techniques that the right demanded when
dismissing the victim accounts about
discrimination as of mere anecdote
unquote when one thinks about the status
of scientific Authority in the realm of
legal discourse one usually thinks the
lawyer types right of of evidentiary
issues raised by the Supreme Court in a
case called Dalbert versus meryl forms
Merrell Dow pharmaceuticals which set
forth the conditions under which expert
evidence will be admitted at trial as
relevant or reliable yet as Sheila
jasanoff notes quote since the early
years of industrialization belief has
grown in legal circles that scientific
evidence is one of the most reliable
kinds of evidence and that science can
deliver insights into matters otherwise
hidden from judicial inquiries part of
its appeal right the hope she continues
though is that technology through its
mechanical reproducibility will be
impervious to context right connects
back this Sally Mary's idea
stripping things of their context and
will provide unbiased and reliable
evidence about the facts of the matter
human actions however can never be
entirely ruled out of the picture in the
production of evidence so scientifically
observed phenomenon in other words as as
Nancy was pointing out earlier do not
speak for themselves
right they are to the contrary for all
practical purposes unreadable unless
they are made to speak with the aged aid
of specialized laboratory techniques
scientific evidence expert testimony all
of which demand the work of trained
professionals again as jazz Knopf puts
it quote facts are not pure unmediated
renditions of an external reality whose
objectivity is secured by a single
transcendent scientific method in
producing scientific facts especially on
previously unstudied problems scientists
must engage in complex debates about the
correctness of particularly Riis
experimental methods experimental
instrumental techniques validation
procedure statistical analyses and so
forth like science law and politics have
their own institutional constraints and
imperatives doing justice and promoting
public welfare follow different
processes and priorities but the hope
and the illusion that science and
scientists can offer some sort of
unmediated access to objective truths
about social life pervades behavioural
realism
thus behavioral realisms embrace of
measurement like its acceptance of the
conservative framing of affirmative
action which is a whole separate
discussion provides a foundation for a
broader and more problematic elevation
of quantitative methods of analysis over
qualitative and the attendant
subordination of legal to scientific
Authority and not just legal authority
but more des sort of democratic forms of
public discourse debt political
discourse we see this powerfully
articulated in Kang and Banerjee's
assertion that quote the metis is a
slightly extended quote but bear with me
the methodology of behavioural realism
forces the law to confront an
increasingly accurate description of
human decision-making and behavior as
provided by the social biological and
physical sciences behavioural realism
identifies naive theories of human
behavior latent in the law and legal
institutions and then juxtaposes these
theories against the best scientific
knowledge available to expose gaps
between assumptions embedded in law and
reality described by science
when behavioral realisms identifies a
substantial gap the law should be
changed to comport with science
this statement is significant not simply
because it is uttered by two leading
proponents of behavioural realism but
also because it's so clearly sets forth
the basic premise upon of central to so
many behavioural realists that the
authority of science should be elevated
over that of the law in engaging issues
of race and racism in American society
the basic frame here is that science can
fix the law make it better bring it more
in accord with reality if only science
is allowed to lead the way this reflect
this frame reflects again what jazz and
off characterized as the signal
disenchantment of contemporary America
with the laws capacity to resolve the
manifold technical disputes of modernity
and a concomitant embrace of the
imagined clarity certainty and
rationality of science
similarly in echo Sally Mary's
observation that the move towards
empirical evidence based governance
quote removes responsibility from
judicial and political decision makers
to the experts in quantification who
develop and implement measurement
systems what does it mean as a practical
matter to say that the law should be
made to comport with science this is a
way of saying that science can see
things about races
that the law cannot that the data of
behavioural realism are superior to
legal understandings of racism that draw
upon interpretive understandings of
history culture and society behavioral
realisms elevation of scientific
authority over legal authority is
further premise on a problematically
stark separation between the two right
the idea that instead of them sort of
mutually informing and working together
it really sort of like one following the
other and that this by the way you know
I'm not talking I'm not meaning to
science bash here in any risk in any
means well you know I'm talking about
putting two different regimes of
authoritative discourse into a more
productive dialogue with each other
racism however needs to be understood
only secondarily as an empirical
phenomenon measured by I 80s or fMRIs
it is first and foremost a function of
context of meaning and power measurement
necessarily must be second Darrell
secondary because we must employ
qualitative knowledge to interpret or
argue about what such measurements mean
or what should just be measured in the
first place the technology is never
transparent this is not to say that
technologies or measurements of racial
attitudes are not real but rather that
they are not pure that is they cannot
meaningfully exist outside of a value
Laden human Enterprise interpretive
enterprises we see this perhaps of we
see perhaps the ultimate subordination
of legal to scientific Authority in
Kang's characterization of judicial
strict scrutiny as a quote algorithm to
be applied as a quote equal protection
machine to detect concealed to quote
detect concealed intent to harm
minorities tanks characterization
resonates eerily with the neuroscience
of recent neuroscience study that
entered fMRI readings taken during the
presentation of different type of
stimuli into a machine learning
algorithm to protect whether an
particular individual undergoing in fMRI
was viewing a black or a white face an
ultimate algorithmic construction of
racial bias in which human judgment need
apply strict scrutiny is typically
understood as a method of legal analysis
invoked by judges when reviewing a legal
classification based on what's known as
a suspect category such as race right in
these cases judges require that the
classification be narrowly tailored to
serve a compelling state interest that's
basically what you know the standard
definition of strict scrutiny an
algorithm of course is a step by step
means of solving a problem but its
derivation and prime meaning comes from
the solving of mathematical problems
algorithms drive computer programs not
judges but behavioural realists would
have judges act like computers or at
least more like computers like their
more conservative counterparts in law
and economics behavioral realists would
take the judgment out of judging the
idea here is that if you have only the
proper metric inputs and then the equal
protection machine will provide a true
empirically verifiable answer but law is
not math although empirical information
may be very important for informing
legal judgments certain legal judgments
it in and of itself cannot make those
judgments just as John Marshall Harlan s
dissent in Poe versus Ullman in 1961
sort of precursor to the Griswold case
on privacy speaks in eloquent
counterpoint the Kang's idea that strict
scrutiny can or should be reduced to an
algorithm due process wrote Harlan has
not been reduced to any formula its
content cannot be determined by
reference to any code the best that can
be said is that through the course of
this Court's decisions it has
represented the balance which our nation
built upon postulates of respect for the
liberty of the individual has struck
between that liberty and the demands of
organized society no formula could serve
as a substitute in this area for
judgment and restraint yet substituting
a formula for judgment is precisely the
implication of behavioural realisms
fascination with measurement and the
application of measurement to law
through scientifically guided algorithms
one cannot say that the majority opinion
in Plessy versus Ferguson the separate
but he
case would somehow empirically incorrect
or that Warren's opinion in Brown versus
Board of Education was somehow
empirically correct at least not in the
same way that you can talk about you
know Ptolemies idea of the earth at the
center of the of the universe you know
was empirically you know incorrect
relative to the Copernican system right
this is for the for the simple reason
right that that the difference between
black brown and Plessy is an argument
right and argument about the meaning of
segregation it's not it's not as sort of
an empirically determine --all
determinable phenomenon although
arguments about the meaning of
segregation may be informed by empirical
data they cannot be resolved by it a
recent report by investigative
journalists in ProPublica which probably
everybody's familiar with here cast into
high relief some of the pitfalls of
seating too much authority to supposedly
objective metrically based algorithms in
the field of criminal justice titled
machine bias there's a software software
used across the country to predict
future criminals and spiced against
blacks the report examines the practical
effects of risks at risk assessment
algorithms that are used in courtrooms
across the country to inform decisions
about you know every stage of the
criminal justice process and just sort
of skipping through cutting to the chase
right they they exhibit consistent and
pervasive bias against people of color
who have you know similarly situated
right put into the fed into these
algorithms and bias results so and those
are those are also if they've been other
obviously the whole theme of this right
there have been many other studies
showing similar kind of biases in other
areas you know granting you know loans
and
so the shortcomings of this are out
algorithmic approach for bias assessment
and management can be brought into
further relief by science studies
scholars critiques of similar
algorithmic approaches to other areas of
risk assessment and management experts
have frequently been baffled by public
resistance to the acceptance of their
pronouncements regarding a wide range of
risks typically in the fields of fields
of health and environmental management
for instance popular protests over GMOs
or nuclear power particularly prominent
in European countries expert the
bafflement often takes the form of
characterizing the public is suffering
from some form of knowledge or
understanding deficit that is popular
Democratic resistance to the
unquestioning acceptance of scientific
Authority is deemed as somehow
irrational or ignorant on its face the
knowledge deficit model is based upon
the assumption that expert forms of
knowledge provide a sufficient basis for
deciding the most important public
policy questions in this view public
perceptions and beliefs that route that
run counter to this expert knowledge
provide unacceptable justifications for
public policies instead support of
expert knowledge needs to be built
through education and various public
relations strategies
tellingly this public deficit model
identifies the problem as exterior to
the scientific enterprise and we see
this you know in many areas right it's
like the problem we know that we're you
know it's it's always somebody else's
problem right not our problem that we're
not realizing what what do you want in
proposing the scientific method of
cognitive psychology and neuroscience is
a basis for breaking through the impasse
of current equal protection law
behavioral realists imply if only
conservative jurists and policy makers
know the facts as we can present them
then they would surely embrace racial
amelioration through affirmative action
in other related programs that is
behavioral realists cast the legal
community itself as suffering from a
sort of knowledge or understanding
deficit that can be remedied by
embracing imperialist realists
scientific findings
not only is this stance empirically
questionable but it also further
subordinates legal to scientific
Authority in a manner that blurs the
relation between normative and factual
issues as well as between legal and
scientific questions just as the
risk-benefit analysis of much of law and
economics research often blurs the
distinction between empirical questions
of measurement and normative questions
of what to measure and how to define
risks and benefits in the first place so
too does behavioural realisms focus on
gauging milisecond responses to an IAT
or on reading an fMRI image X obscure
the antecedent normative questions of
why we are measuring those outputs and
how we define the meaning of the results
yet can characterize its behavioural
realism itself as an algorithm that he
explicitly contrasts with the more
common sense judgment of forms of
judgment based on again so-called naive
psychological theories right now law as
naive science is sophisticated
privileged inalca rhythms privileges
experts experts are primarily
accountable to other experts not to
judges and certainly not to naive sidon
citizens behavioural realism not only
elevates scientific authority over legal
authority but it also elevates
unaccountable experts over officers and
citizens of a democratic polity its
valorisation of all things metric made
thus marginalize interpretive legal
authority or just interpretive in just
the interpretive enterprise itself and
broader demikhov product and the broader
democratic impulses upon which it rests
such lack of accountability tends to
reinforce existing structures of power
as Frank Dobbin and Alexandre Calif note
in their review of the diversity
management industry the ones based or
the and in these particular programs the
programs based on psychological and
behavioral interventions to reshape
reshape individual managers attitudes
generally fail right they don't actually
increase workplace diversity only
programs with firm lines of
responsibility and account
ability show any sort of result
similarly many behavioral realist
interventions in the legal system are
targeted at changing judges attitudes
and seating all authority to measure and
interpret redress and institutional rate
realism to behavioral realist experts so
just in closing then the basic idea here
is you know well as I've just sort of
said that right you know we don't want
to be reflexively seating too much
authority in this regard trying to
reconcile a scientific and legal and
more democratic forms of authority
interpretive and quantitative pushing
towards more a larger sort of progress
racial progress right one thing can be
sure right no algorithm is going to to
get us there right it's going to be hard
messy dirty political work right which
isn't to say algorithms are irrelevant
but they they can't do the work for us
[Applause]
sorry
[Music]
vicious commentary it very few see you
are you ready okay so our our next
speaker is Harriet Washington an author
of Medical apartheid and vicious badness
lecture and bioethics at Columbia
your own pockets today good afternoon
I'm going to speak about a few issues
having to do with race and IQ or
intelligence take your pick and not
comprehensive certainly but there are a
lot of questions that have gone
unanswered when it comes to looking at
the copious amount of data that um
strengthens and supports are it adhering
agenda and unfortunately also supports
the response to hereditary an agenda so
I'm going to have a lot of slides here
I'll skip a lot of them but if I skip
one that you really want to discuss it's
bring it up later during the panel so um
evidence of absence I actually in put in
mind rephrase at Robert Bullard the
father environmental racism put to me
once when I told him I was concerned
about them lacking in Haines data
pertaining to an african-american
reliant on subsistence fishing Johns
Hopkins expert told me we have bad about
Asians but nothing about
african-americans and if we don't have
the data it doesn't exist
and butlered said evidence of absence of
evidence does not equate to evidence of
absence so um just because dad aren't
there doesn't mean that they're not they
don't exist and that they're certain
doesn't mean they're not pertinent I'm
gonna talk about a lot of pertinent data
that we tend to um ignore our military
ins are an interesting Bunch they have
been around for a very long time I would
argue they've been around as long as our
country has been and probably before
these are people who initially had some
quite data free beliefs about
african-americans that we still
subscribe to today African American
intelligence they said was a genetically
mediated heritable permanent fixed and
color coded not just african-americans
but Asians whites Native Americans you
could determine the average intelligence
of these groups because Nature had
helpfully color-coded them for us
one of the they did a lot of talking
about that they present a lot of data
about that but one thing that they don't
do much talking about is what is
intelligence and when I put the question
to some researchers who have spent their
entire career as refining our knowledge
of the field they didn't actually have
any active answers either one researcher
said to me that's a very that's a good
question a very good question then he
fell into silence Arthur Jensen who had
a great deal to say when he was at
Harvard about the lower intelligence of
African Americans or as he put them
negroes and their causes and the effects
for society how we should treat them
knowing that they're lower in
intelligence and always will be he wrote
about this quite extensively but when
asked to define intelligence he said
intelligence like electricity is easier
to measure than to define what is
nonsensical little aphorism could be
refuted by any high school student who
could easily tell you electricity is a
flow of electrons but still he was
revered and respected as an authority on
the subject so we don't really know what
intelligence is we actually current
thinking is that it's a collection of
attributes it's like being attractive
it's not just your skin color your hair
color or your height or your figure it's
a combination of all these things an
emerging quality and intelligence
something we don't have a finger on we
don't know what it is but we're very
very assiduous about measuring it and so
we measure it with IQ although they
often speak to intelligence and
measuring IQ and what is IQ measuring
women a said it did not measure a
person's um general ability it didn't
predict who was going to be a good
performer or a poor performer but we we
ignore that we treat IQ as if it is
indeed a fixed innate genetically
mediated measure of intelligence but
it's not what IQ actually does measuring
measures fairly well is achievement how
well you read or write what your
vocabulary is like how well you handle
numbers
how well you do abstract reasoning and
these are all qualities very important
for success in the Western world very
important for success and not so
important for success other work other
places in the world one researcher put
up very succinctly I really liked what
he put he said
IKEA will tell you if you're going to be
a good office worker it won't tell you
if you're going to be a good farmer and
yet we treat it as if it were a
universal measure the hereditary and of
course the book the bell curve came out
went almost 30 years ago now but it
still is a hereditary enviable to spells
by a lot of people who's never never
cracked its covers but believe fervently
in it and have been swayed by the charts
graphs all the dense tables of data all
these things impress people
so the Nobel Prizes because several
Reddit Aryans are Nobel laureates so I'm
but they're impressed by numbers and
we've accepted IQ as a metric for
intelligence but these numbers are
numbers that are not very well
understood by a lot of people who read
the books and perhaps not by all the
people who write the books on it's my
opinion that Herrnstein the co-author of
the bell curve was the expert in charles
murray has made statements that lead me
to question his understanding of
genetics so we have this and then we
also have the opposition people don't
agree with him unfortunately the
opposition consists of people who are
playing the hereditary ins game a
numbers game they're debating the
important of the numbers they're
debating Spearman's G they're debating
all these relativistic and reductionist
data without ever asking themselves what
do these data really mean and what do
they not mean we have these reductionist
blinders and we look at this data and
we're not asking question we should be
asking about the real factors inherent
in intelligence we also have a
collective um safer rispa phobia in this
country where people are afraid of math
and that works too the reddit Aryans
advantage no one including me is going
to hold herself or herself up to
ridicule by looking through the charts
and the bell curve and s hating to
criticize them
most people can't they don't really
understand them and they're going and
many people will blithely accept them
because they're actually in concert with
what they secretly believe or want to
believe so it's registering in
Tourette's my phobia is quite handy and
again even the critics of hereditary ins
tend to play their game I think that
there's also the role of authority which
I'll say a bit about later if we have
time but people like James Watson who
James Watson
interesting fellow he was a bell curve
in which he thoroughly maligned his um
rival the head of the other lab Roslyn
Fisher rosalind Franklin and he shows
his hoar him as misogyny for decades he
wrote in the book in which he reinforced
it but about ten years ago he's changed
without misogyny for racism when he told
them UK newspapers that he was a reddit
Arian he would leave in an innate
inferiority of black people they were
intellectually inferior they should not
be allowed to reproduce same rates they
were never going to be able to improve
them training won't improve the mission
won't improve them and he was stripped
of most of his titles and but allowed to
keep a few until only last year he
opened his mouth again and refuted his
recantation by saying that's right
blacks are inferior at which point they
stripped him of everything also there
was a very interesting article around
that point where um Kari Stefansson head
of the decode laboratories in Iceland
revealed that Watson had submitted a DNA
sample as part of a project some years
ago when they analyzed it they found
that Watson had 16 times more genetic
component of African descent than the
average European that's right he's black
he's an octoroon if we're going to look
at the numbers okay
1/16 African so malicious ironies of
this their fleet me they're far more but
what's really interesting is that as
other speakers have alluded to before
now technology is a really important
linchpin in the creation of race not
only real technology but also faux
technology one of the interesting things
in Robert V Guthrie's wonderful book
which I highly recommend it's called
even the rat was white its history of
psychology from the point of view of
African Americans and he said
psychologists suffer from physic injury
Envy they wanted to be seen as a hard
science so from the beginning they've
been they've adopted tools preferably in
brass and others other technological you
know elements that harken to those of
physics you know to look like a hard
science the measurement the physics etc
this is a body of knowledge that is not
terribly compelling scientifically or
logically but very compelling when it
comes to imaginations of people and the
desire of people to see this as hard
science rather than as the embodiment of
bias and I often speak about the
American school of ethology beginning in
the 16th century right through the 19th
century these were the scientists who
told the world who African Americans
were and one of the basic things about
African Americans they felt the world
needed to know is how unintelligent
African Americans were and they all
agreed upon this they thought they they
thought black people might not be part
of the same species but they were sure
that even if they were their
intelligence was low and could never be
elevated to that of a white person so
again very early belief data free that
has persisted until the present day
in fact we had a really interesting
episode in 1840 1840 was an interesting
year and that people don't realize it
but slavery was on life support a
Virginia the legislature came within
eight votes of abolishing slavery and
there was anti-slavery sentiment was
burgeoning and the North was callously
not even lean the taking advantage of
this because they they I don't know how
much they cared about freeing enslaved
people but they certainly did resented
the power that's all these black bodies
were giving the South in the legislature
so how to protect enslavement you know
line had been for a long time that
southern whites needed enslavement they
depended on the non-diversified on a
barren economy depended on free labor
but now the argument changed to now it's
African Americans who need enslavement
they can't survive without it
John C Calhoun had been a medical
student he was Secretary of State and he
appointed a close friend to run the
census and for the first time they
looked at African Americans and whites
but they divided African Americans into
black and enslaved and when the data of
the sentence were printed they found
that free African Americans were 11
times more likely than enslaved one to
be insane
so enslavement was necessary for the
health mental health of African
Americans and you had southern doctors
lining up to say we've been telling you
for years these blacks can't survive on
their own now are you believing because
after all it was census data we're not
talking about the screed or some rabid
you know segregationist we're talking
about the US Census and the person who
refuted him was the first man to earn a
medical degree who was African American
he didn't earn it here because no one
would accept him he was denied admission
on on niggardly race racial bars
he went to Glasgow Scotland to medical
school where he was a valedictorian and
he also took a degree in statistics he
was a perfect person to refute the
census data when he came back to the
u.s. that's exactly what he did he went
to the Senate floor and issued a
memorial point-by-point refuting all
data some of the data were like frankly
false and for example there was one a
sane asylum in Massachusetts have listed
133 insane black people but he found
that there was 133 white people so that
was on that level of falsification
unfortunately though if you look to the
medical literature you can still find
medical papers citing census data 50
years later that they had never been
refuted by MacKinnon
so an early lesson in the persistence of
data that are flawed but speak to a
racial bias a favorite a cherished
racial bias and there are a number of
books that had been written in the past
very good books this one I mentioned
already Steven Jacobs mismeasure of man
he also talked about the data that were
being collected that were falsified and
rigged in order to show that African
Americans had lower intelligence and
whites and more frequently more recently
we've had some excellent books that look
at um that current data so one of the
problems one of the ways we've gone
wrong here is that in looking at IQ and
looking at IQ we've been data we've been
focused on genetics the assumption which
has never been proven that IQ is driven
by genetics is something that frankly
does not stand up well with scrutiny
because it have never been a single gene
found many many Dean's found that
alleged to be implied in intelligence
but first of all if you can't define an
entity how are you going to establish
causation it's not compelling and we
have chosen not to look at compelling
data for example infection one of the
things that we tend not to look at her I
think pay enough attention to is copious
data showing that infection infectious
disease are closely correlated with
intelligence it's not surprising this
should be so many infectious diseases
attack the brain directly others cause
fevers that cause collateral damage and
others
lower intelligence simply by harming the
brain of fetal fetuses and newborns a
newborn child devotes 86% of its
metabolic energy to building a brain a
complex brain if a newborn child is
infected which is the case with most
children in Africa and part of the
global South fighting off this infection
and building the brain both
metabolically costly tasks baby can't do
beause that baby's brain will be damaged
it'll be flawed the baby might have had
the genetic potential of a genius or an
Einstein but he's likely be boring with
a deficit and that's important to
understand the genetic potential is just
that potential environment Trump's it at
every turn this is a very good example
there are many more in this country here
few few charts it's an article I wrote
for the American scholar about neglected
tropical diseases and how they are
damaging the cognitive abilities of kids
in the global south and adults
here's a book I wrote about how microbes
and our microbiomes affect our mental
health so something that I think there
is much more scrutiny and currently I'm
we're I've actually just completed a
book that looks at environmental toxins
toxicants heavy metals even microbes
pesticides PCBs these have profound
these cause profound injury to the
brains of human beings and particularly
children particularly fetuses for the
same reason that infection will cause
their brain not through just potential
exposure to these toxins and toxicants
especially early on will do so but even
adult brains are not free from so we all
know this but likely researchers have
been quantifying it very useful ways for
example we now know that exposure to
lead in this country results in the loss
of 23 million IQ points per cohort every
year that's a lot of IQ points and who's
being most profoundly affected people of
color these are the people who live near
these um tops expelling coal-fired
merchant plants that spew mercury lead
arsenic other heavy metals so these are
the people who are the most heavily
affected I'm not implying that it's only
Cox exposures alone but environment is a
it's a vastly underappreciated a
component of cognitive damage and this
is what's driving differences in IQ in
my opinion I'm running out of time to
I'm not going to go into a lot more
detail is more to say but not more time
but I will say that um although IQ is a
deeply flawed metric it is useful for
something one thing it's very useful for
is assessing one's achievement
it doesn't actually measure potential
where it isn't like us to believe but it
doesn't measure achievement and so
looking at who is able to do achieve
certain important tests in the West like
me literate for example be able to count
well to do analyses who's able to do
that does give us a meaningful metric
for looking at who's
brain has been damaged and the racial
nature is very important too because
although very often subscribed a
socio-economic exposure in fact Flint
the first two years was described as a
region where poor people lived only
after two years of a state say ok
they're primarily African Americans we
are living in a country a nation of
Flint and across our nature is poor
people of color for the worst time but
also middle middle class people of color
and for example African Americans who
earn 60,000 dollars a year are more
heavily exposed to toxicants than white
people who earn twenty thousand dollars
a year
so although poverty puts you at risk
race puts you at higher risk and I think
that a wind up here thanks so much for
listening to me
[Applause]
biomedical sciences at Stanford
all right great thank you thanks Cynthia
so I'll tell you about a third of work
that I've been doing with a lot of
collaborators for the last two or three
years thinking about how language and
texts and stereotypes in language and
text affect algorithms and how can we
use algorithms to study stereotypes in
humans so it's a collaboration with and
based on discussions there's a lot of
people from computer science also from
the social sciences including many of
the folks here in this room so I am a
machine learning researcher right so we
work on a lot of different types of data
including genomics data image data and
what I find the most interesting about
text data especially for this context is
that the text data is actually really
fundamental and it's really at the roots
for a lot of the algorithms that we
develop right so if you think about
staying the kinds of interactions you
have was your phone was your computer
and soon to be was a self-driving cars
or a lot of that is actually through
language and through text so it's really
sort of the fuel and the roots of many
of the of the machine learning
algorithms and developments so the other
thing that's interesting about text
especially think for thinking about
stereotypes and bias is that when we
interact with the algorithms oftentimes
humans interact with atoms through
language through text right when you
talk to your phone you're actually
verbally communicating with it where you
if you were to chat piping on to the
chat bot to write your pet sending in
text right so to the extent that the
algorithms are continuously being
trained retrained and updated based on
it's based on this information based on
new data there's actually sort of a
closed loop of updating through these
algorithms so the other thing that's
interesting about text is that it's
actually quite different from prediction
from classification right so earlier
today we heard a lot of interesting
talks about what are the biases and
challenges for thinking about
inequalities right in prediction and
classification so to some extent
text actually happens upstream of that
right so text is often a way to generate
features and then those features are fed
into the specific prediction algorithms
you know for biomedical applications or
for different recommendation systems
right but before you make the
you first have to have representations
and features of your data and what we
want to focus on today is even before
you get to the prediction part which may
already be too late right so how do the
different stereotypes creepy and even in
the feature ization in the
representations of your data right so
the kinds of challenges and techniques
we'll look at here it's also quite
different from predictions in
predictions for example you've heard
from Santos nice talk about you have
different risk scores you can do
calibration here it's actually in some
sense much more unsupervised right so we
don't have very specific objectives so
which presents other challenges so so
for the talk today I want to tell you
about for two threads of work so surface
slightly earlier sort of works is how do
we think about how human stereotypes in
language in text sort of creep into and
affect algorithms through these
representations and more recent threat
of work which were also interested in is
how can we actually leverage the fact
that algorithm is actually quite good at
capturing these biases as a way to turn
the problem around right so make these
algorithms as a mirror to study our own
stereotypes and own biases especially in
settings where it's hard to quantify
otherwise alright so so the first
problem it's more of how can these
issues affect computer science and the
second frameworks how can we actually
use these tools of computer science to
study social questions I think they're
quite complimentary ok cool so since we
have a quite diverse audience here so I
wanted to give you a one-minute primer
so that you're all experts on how these
algorithms represent these kinds of data
so that's if you're actually trying to
build various applications right to make
predictions were some natural language
systems and you are starting with text
data with training data right so usually
I serve an intermediate step or initial
step how this all works is that's you
first basically map your words into
vectors right so these are basically
embeddings or dictionaries you can think
them or feature editions of your words
it's the idea here is that if somehow
the geometry is between the vectors
right captures the semantic relations
between the corresponding English words
then you have now a new representation
new feature ization
in other words that makes
easier to comprehend by the downstream
prediction algorithms so every English
words you know like Simon's or Berkeley
or dog and cat it's not mapped into its
own vector and you can think of them as
being some sort of geometries between
these vectors okay so people in text and
especially in natural language
processing part of computer science have
developed a lot of ways to study how
good are these representations so a
common kind of approach is to basically
give these representations its little
puzzles to solve and see how well can it
solve these puzzles
alright so standard kind of puzzles are
for example what you might have taken in
SATs right from high school to Asami's
analogy pathos like - the king is Romans
- blank and they've suffering like then
these algorithm to say okay so that'd be
analogous to what mr. Queen right and
then gets a you know a good so so
starting from about three years ago so
what we wanted to do is to first can we
design a set of puzzles to really
quantify what are the potential
stereotypes in these word
representations right because despite
the fact that these algorithms and these
representations have been now been used
in many many applications both academic
and industry applications people
actually haven't quite carefully checked
by systematically what are the potential
human stereotypes that shows up in these
representations and we think that is
being quite fundamental step if you want
to understand what are the biases in all
these downstream of prediction problems
so we basically designed a bunch of
probes and you know I think since you
have been very rather passive audience
for the last hour so I want to make this
more interactive right so so each of
this is basically one of the puzzles
that we give to the standard inviting
algorithms and I would like each of you
to predict what you think the algorithm
returns us as its answer so we start
with the easy one okay doctor architect
someone say interior designer okay good
I guess yeah so what about realist this
is a harder one pessimist optimist okay
[Applause]
so some interesting insights you can
also flip this around I can ask okay so
she's to pregnancy is he is to okay okay
fatherhood's okay maybe that would be
natural when I presented this to
actually to some physicians suppositions
came up and said that this is the
analogy that the physician actually
explains yes exactly it's to explain
pain to the wife yeah
the Delta misters already so if we lived
in a country where more the doctors were
women we all know said nurse that's a
good question so so this is actually
algorithms in betting outs that are
trained on data sets so we tried this on
data sets
most of the data actually come from the
US so if you actually train this and
other people have tried training this on
data from other countries and sometimes
that often has actually observed similar
results right but there are some
interesting differences there was a
paper that was posted at tackle or maybe
was ACL this year I showed that a lot of
these analogies that a is the PSC's to
be turn out that way because everyone's
using eval code the original words of a
key Val code which doesn't allow you to
return B yes yeah no so so this is the
doctor she is the doctor yes just to be
clarify so there's no exclusion here
right so we used a different analogy
algorithm that actually allowed you to
explore to return any words sorry so for
example doctor would be allowed here so
it actually does show up but it just
actually shows up after nurse right and
after midwife and offer a few other
things
you're saying ass yeah so we actually
have a so the returns you base they have
a ranking of these right so dr. is shows
up is it is allowed so there's no
exclusion so it is loud and the doctor
just shows up after languages where
there's a difference between female and
male yes we have maybe I'll come back to
that at the end if that's because I
think there's a more more intricate
discussion we need to have about
different languages here okay okay so
the last one is okay so we do you know
computer programmer so as a probe right
so these analogies would say that's
analogous to homemaker right again it is
allowed to return computer programmer
but actually just chose homemaker as it
thinks it's for the more appropriate
analogy so so this is actually just a
illustration right so these in the
representations in the future ization
itself there's already a lot of human
stereotypes gender stereotypes and also
ethnic and other cultural stereotypes of
can you actually upload into these
analogies into into the representations
and we actually have systematically
verified this now know through quite a
pretty large scale citizen science where
we essentially automatically generate
these analogies for each of those
actually give it to a lot of people to
basically evaluate they said the social
analysis agree with their own
perceptions of what are problematic
gender stereotypes right just to see
that they do actually that the biases in
embedding this match up quite accurately
was human stereotypes
and the reason why I want to emphasize
why we think there's this this is being
quite problematic is that again these
feature ization is really one of the
first steps you do right see if you do
any other predictions on top of this
this is somehow analogous to teaching
children trying to do more complicated
things when the dictionary let's know
that you give them in the very beginning
to teach them what are the meanings of
words I already have these stereotypes
that are baked into it and we and others
have shown that's for a lot of the
downstream applications for both
predictions and actually things in
deployment these kinds of biases do
types in the representation can lead to
an intent and sometimes harmful
consequences so okay so so what do we do
with this right so I think this is
actually quite a complex a nuanced
question because there are some
applications where you think that's
having these kinds of stereotypes built
into the representation in the
visualization might be useful if you are
for example trying to do recommendation
systems for clothing maybe you do want
to have the gender stereotypes put in
but in other applications for trying to
build these systems for ranking of
college applicants or resumes you want
to be much more careful about any of
these potential stereotypes so so
there's I think a lot of really healthy
and interesting discussions about how do
we what are what are settings when this
is appropriate or inappropriate and what
do we do of this but I think in all of
these settings what is useful is to
actually be able to perform kind of
control factor analysis all right so
what I mean by that is that now if you
have your machine learning pipeline but
maybe it's making predictions or
rankings and it's taking in these text
features is text representations is one
features you'll be useful to know how
does your pipeline actually change if
you keep everything else the same keep
the I pipeline the same but just change
the text representation to reduce some
of these gender stereotypes or ethnic
stereotypes I think of that as sort of a
perturbation or sensitivity analysis
just see how sensitive is your machine
learning complex ai prediction results
based on this part
representation that's using these
genders through all type information and
you then you can decide whether this is
appropriate or not but this is useful
information just for for transparency so
this is actually the motivation for our
initial work which is trying to come up
with to basically create to do this kind
of concert fracture analysis by creating
these kind of reduce the new
representations less bias the technical
details are less important I just wanna
give you the high level intuition how
how we take a step to doing with that
all right so the idea here is that if
you remember each English word now it's
mapped onto your vector where the child
shape of the factories are not important
so what we did is I actually found that
yours actually seems like a pretty low
dimensional subspace that corresponds to
gender stereotypes there's a quite a
deep reason why that happens but it did
this it does exist empirically and then
essentially what we do is typically take
words that does not really have
dictionary definition of gender in build
into it basis just read project away the
contribution from this gender subspace
so the actual algorithm is a little bit
more complicated but it's the high-level
idea right and by doing this we can
actually show that okay so now you
actually produce against you cross
worsening experiments citizen science
experiment in generates sort of inviting
algorithms now that has less bias and
that's actually how we can validate and
our collaborators some co-authors
validated that it is such these gender
information
that led to some of the biases in
downstream applications such as serve
entity recognition which is their
standard enough key task yet and
actually in this case the contractor
analysis shows that if you can actually
if you reduce the stereotypes in the
text representation you can actually
improve the performance for this
downstream natural anguish processing
task
question how did you stop it going
we didn't I'm asking you how you managed
to get it to go dr. doctor but not okay
oh okay good so so what I skimmed over
is that when we actually do this
projection to reduce the bias right so
we first essentially learn a classifier
to figure out which words should be
corrected because they should be truly
gender-neutral and which words has
gender building this definition in the
hence should not be changed right so in
this case these words like for the
occupational words we think really
should be gender-neutral are the ones
that we actually do the correction and
words like king and queen or he and she
that you know if you actually look at
the dictionary definition has gender
built into it we do not change so maybe
that's a little yes so that's that's how
we do
so there are I think that this is
basically really a first step right and
since there's been a lot of improvements
on these kinds of methods to reduce
these bias and and just want to make a
quick comment that reducing it by itself
I think it's also quite challenging and
can be undesirable in many applications
right so so for example I mean there's a
lot of great discussions earlier today
about thinking take into account the
broader social context essentially what
we're doing here is a very agnostic
algorithm that just simply you know
training some classifier to say what
words should and should not be
gender-neutral and doing these numerical
operations or that's really not taking
account the broader context so that's
something I think we as a community
should be much better on try to improve
this into these algorithms so the second
aspect of the talk I want to more
quickly go through is now that we've
shown that these algorithms these
embeddings and positions are so
effective at capturing human stereotypes
can we actually turn this problem around
and use these algorithms as a mirror to
study your own stereotypes especially in
settings where maybe we have implicit
biases implicit stereotypes are hard to
quantify otherwise so one studying words
actually very hard to quantify what are
the implicit zero types and human biases
is actually on historical data so it's
hard to go back into past and conduct
surveys or content experiments so one
thing we did is basically actually take
google books right over the last 100
years and we have all the source text
data we can bc do the same idea as i
showed you before
at each time period since you train
these representations trainees
visualizations and then to see how does
the embeddings actually evolve over the
last 100 years right and see can we
actually use how to involve anybody's
been changing over the last hundred
years as a way to study how has human
stereotypes and for gender and and no
general ethics your times how has that
changed in evolved over the last 100
years
this is basically mostly as a lens to
study social science and I'll just
quickly show you a few highlights of the
results much more of the results are in
the paper that we published last year
so one thing that's a great personal
interest is to study how has stereotypes
in the u.s. towards Asian Americans how
has that changed over the last hundred
years it's something that a lot of
people talked about but that actually
has not been a lot of systematic
quantifications of it so here I'm
showing you using similar techniques
from the first part of the talk right
what are the adjectives from each of
these time periods that are the most
associated with Chinese Americans right
from 1910 1950 and 1990 the top ten
adjectives and this actually be
something that's already quite striking
and also striking to us right so in 1910
you have additives like barbaric mvs or
monstrous hateful right very much
framings of outsiders or aliens even
right so that's actually start to change
a lot after World War two 1950s and by
1990s you changed quite completely into
framings about you know sensitive or
inhibited so much more of stereotypes
about sort of model minorities alright
so I think there are certainly complex
issues with all these different
stereotypes especially now as it
pertains to college admissions but
certainly it's interesting to be able to
quantify this and see how they have
involved over time so the other thing is
interesting is that we have these text
data we also have a lot of data from the
social sciences from for example from
the US census for example we can see
again across each of these time periods
right how has the actual various
occupation participation by Chinese
Americans in different occupations how
did that actually evolve over time and
how does that change was the steroid
matchup was a stereotypes
towards Asian Americans in the same time
period so basically just to summarize
this like the the green curve here
actually shows you essentially the
occupational bias from the US Census
where's the blue one corresponds to
basically the embedding bias from the
text data so you can see that they
actually tracked quite closely the bias
becomes greater right around World War
two
right and then it became sort of became
more neutral after that and another
thing that this allows us to do is to
quantify what are potentially some of
the legislations that might be
correlated where it might even be causal
in a ways to change these stereotypes so
here it's a little bit complex plot but
the high-level idea here is that
basically looking and since we have the
embedding at each time period we can see
how does the embedding correlate whose
nearby time period there's a way to see
how fast is it changing so this is
basically like a correlation map of how
fast these embeddings or how fast the
stereotypes are changing across time
based on text data you can essentially
see a couple sort of fetish striking in
phase transitions were around 19th 1950
1960 there's a quite a rapid change in
the stereotypes in the text data and
that actually corresponds to the past it
was 1965 of the immigration Nationality
Act which actually made it much easier
for Asians to know to become naturalized
u.s. citizens and to come to the US we
talked similar kinds of analysis
northward for different ethnic groups
also for gender so here also some of the
top adjectives across the last 100 years
across different time periods they can
also see some interesting changes and
also there's I guess the most striking
kind of phase transitions as you would
expect around 1960s where we really see
the text and the stereotypes really
quite changed a lot from pre - after
1960s so this we've done for historical
data because that's an area where it's
very hard to quantify know these
stereotypes right but where we think
these kinds of text analysis could be
useful yes
is that the ancient population in play
tonight in that most of the agents in
1910 would have big Chinese I think so
there's also a lot of Japanese
populations yeah right so we actually
stratified this for specifically for
Chinese right we can do this based on
the Chinese names and also for each of
the other groups
right so it's very lousy to wrap up the
first another app because there's a lot
of interest for the biomedical
applications from the earlier session
today so we also did this very quickly
for biomedical data so basically we had
reviews of physicians from large
hospital system for all the reviews from
the last few like five years right
basically for each review the patient
will give a rating for the physician
from one to ten and also will writes a
report like the summary like a feedback
for the physician right so basic we can
do the kinds of analysis where condition
and correcting for the ratings right for
all the reviews both patients I give
high ratings to these physicians what
are the differences in why did the
patient actually give a high rating to
the middle or to the female page with
the female clinician or to physicians
from different ethnic groups and you can
see actually quite interestingly that
the main server rationale that we can
detect on analysis for why high ratings
for female physicians are really related
to serve this know tend to warm friendly
kind of nice feelings worse the the
rationales why given to high male
physician ratings are more with it to no
intelligence accurate experts so you can
see that there's already quite a bit of
differences in how people talk about
these physicians even given the same
scores and this is important because
this review
it says these these reviews are actually
considered by the hospitals when they
give you know think about salaries for
this physician so I think amount of time
just just to very quickly wrap up right
so so when we think about the
transparency problem of these biases and
algorithms I think it's really important
to start from the very beginning to look
at the data and also look at the
representation the feature ization of
your data even before we get into the
predictions and the issues there right
yes this is really getting closer to the
root of these problems and to do this is
actually extremely important for no
computer scientists like us to really
engage where so the social scientists
and humanists and legal scholars
and also presence it's not all bad news
so it also presents an interesting
opportunity to create a new lens and new
tools to study interesting social
science problems
[Applause]